CHRISTOPHER TOWNSEND: So we
literally had stunts go and rig
up on our set with wires and
actually had these characters
being slammed around and moved.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Beware my purr.
My tentacles bite.
I'm Lorraine.
I might have
fallen from space.
I'm Langston.
Ooh, and this is
Earth's Mightiest Show.
Where we talk about all
of the most '90s stuff
in the Marvel universe.
Oh, and if we're going to talk
'90s, let's talk about this.
Higher, further, faster, baby.
Marvel Studios' Captain Marvel
is now available on digital HD.
And it's coming to Blu-ray
and DVD on June 11.
I'm obsessed.
- Oh, listen.
I can't wait for all the
extras, the blooper reel,
deleted scenes, all the stuff.
I want more, please.
Oh my god.
I flerken love this
movie, especially because
of all the '90s goodness.
I'm talking fashion,
soundtracks.
So good.
Oh, the settings.
Come on, Blockbuster Video.
Gourmet choice.
Oh, a delight.
Bringing me back.
And we're going to be talking
more about the '90s today.
But I think first, we
should talk about the fact
that I got to chat with visual
effects supervisor Christopher
Townsend all about
creating Goose the Cat's
cool secret skills,
the Kree-Skrull battle,
and Captain Marvel's big fall.
But spoiler warnings ahead
if you have not seen this film.
But for those of you who
have, you are in for a treat.
This is super cool.
Let's watch.
Oh.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I am here with visual
effects supervisor
Christopher Townsend.
Hello.
- Hi.
How are you doing?
I'm very well.
So everyone has seen
the film by now.
If not, what have you
been doing with your life?
Get it together, people.
I want to talk about some
of the visual effects
that we can finally kind
of discuss, because it's
coming home for home release.
So first of all, I
know we were all very
excited to meet Goose the Cat.
There's a lot more to Goose the
Cat than maybe meets the eye,
like a pocket universe
full of tentacles
or something like that.
CHRISTOPHER TOWNSEND:
Something like that, yes.
As you're starting to
create this alien creature,
where do you start?
I think with--
as with most of these things,
with sort of these characters,
you go back to the comics.
And you look at the comics,
and you look at poster art,
and you look at the art
that's been done of,
what is the flerken?
So it's this big gooey, goopy,
terrifically sized monster sort
of thing that bursts
out of this cat,
and then goes back inside again.
And I think the
fun part was trying
to have that juxtaposition
between the two.
And when you're bringing
that to life, obviously,
the flerken will
interact with the actors.
How do you get him to
interact with other characters
and pull it all together?
It's all very carefully,
carefully orchestrated.
We have one particular scene
where the elite fighting force,
the Kree guards are coming in
and are being slammed around.
So we literally had stunts
go and rig up on our set
with wires, and actually
had these characters
being slammed around and moved,
and flipped, and flopped,
and things.
All that stuff is
very carefully planned
out in our pre-visualization
moment in our previous time.
And we figure out exactly how--
what the moves need
to be based on what
the tentacles are going to do.
So you sort of work backwards.
That's where visual effects
sort of fits in the middle,
as it were.
So speaking of the
Kree and the Skrulls,
there is this large fight
between the two of them.
And there are a lot
of characters there.
How many characters
are being brought
in through visual effects?
And how many are actually there?
We actually shot out--
there's a scene called
Torfa on the planet Torfa.
And we went out and we
shot this at a quarry
for a couple of weeks.
Because of the complexity
of you're shooting outside,
you're shooting at night, you're
shooting in fog, which is never
the same, all these
sort of things
made it incredibly difficult to
actually do it, to pull it off.
But I think what you see
at the end is this sort
of big wide scope of things.
There are maybe 40 or so
real actors in full makeup
and prosthetic masks,
and helmets, and costume,
and everything
else running around
in that sandy sort of quarry.
And then we've added easily
just as many characters
on top in digitally.
It's really a mix
between the sort
of the traditional sort of
stunt work and visual effects.
There is an epic
scene at the end where
Captain Marvel is falling.
It is harrowing.
How do you place that?
Because obviously, we
can't drop Brie Larson.
Yeah, so a lot of-- obviously,
a lot of what we do is
you're trying to make
the impossible possible,
and also making
it, hopefully, look
real so that an audience is
there and never questions it.
And there are many things
we could have tried.
We could have tried skydiving.
We could have tried these
sort of wind tunnels.
We could have
tried her on wires.
We could've tried all
sorts of different things.
One of the things we
realized very quickly
was that for what we needed
for her in this very specific
moment is to be able just to
use a digital double of her,
and be able to just
close in on her face
and be able to use her
face and her expressions
where necessary.
And there's some other
performance involved,
too, because there are some
folks in green screen suits
as well.
There are.
There are people there
that are moving her around
in the blue screen suits.
And they're using that to
try and puppeteer her to make
it feel like she's floating.
Because one of the
problems is-- obviously,
when you're literally
on wires, you're
being supported in a
cradle, or if you're
on a backboard where you're
just being supported,
your legs tend to go down.
So you need to make
it feel like someone
is moving around in a more
naturalistic way as you would
when falling.
We used a lot of
that, not only--
some of it is actually
literally in the film.
Also, a lot of it was
just used as reference
so that we can see how Brie's
body moves in a particular way
and how the costume
moves in a particular way
when she's doing a particular
thing with her arms or legs.
We also shot elements
just of her face.
And so you can imagine we
were sitting in a studio
with her sitting in a chair,
and she's got the helmet on.
And we'd say, OK, look scared!
OK, look over to your left!
Look over to your right!
Oh, now this is happening!
And she was a real
trooper and amazing
to watch, a true
professional as an actor
being able to react
to that, and pretend
that they're falling and
panicking, and looking.
LORRAINE CINK: But
it's just right here.
CHRISTOPHER TOWNSEND:
And it's just here.
And all we're capturing is
just her face and expressions.
And we take all of
that information
and then we would map that.
We would project that
onto a CG version of her.
So what you see in the
final film is generally
a digital version
of her falling,
but with her performance
mapped on her face,
put onto the digital
version of her.
So you also got
to create a very
interesting realm
that we've never
seen in the Marvel universe.
And it's hard to say.
It's more of a
consciousness, we'll
say, the Supreme Intelligence.
How did you build that
interaction world brain space?
What do you call it?
We call it the Supreme
Intelligent Chamber--
Intelligence Chamber.
And I think it was a fascinating
sort of bit of storytelling
that we were trying
to do in there.
There's a lot of exposition
that happens in that room.
There's a lot of sort of
definition of the characters
that happen.
But the idea was that the
room exists in a reality.
It's a virtual reality,
but it should never
look like virtual reality.
It should always feel
like a very real space.
But we wanted to keep
it a little bit surreal.
And we went through
many iterations
from massive green hexagonal
blocks to liquid worlds
to almost Salvador
Dali sort of art.
We went through all
sorts of things,
but eventually ended
up back at this very
minimalist, sort of almost a
white room and a clean room.
And the idea being
that you can almost--
whatever you want to conjure in
that room, you can make happen.
There's obviously-- there's
a point in the movie
where we twist, and
things get a bit
more violent and aggressive.
And then the room itself
begins to collapse.
And it was a really
interesting challenge
to try and figure out how
to create something which
would sort of satisfy both
the serene and the violent
all at once.
Well, it is beautiful
and very serene.
And I would very much like
to have that in my home.
Not the latter half--
Yes.
But the first part, very nice.
Thank you so much.
You're very welcome.
Oh, my pleasure.
You guys, be sure to watch
Marvel Studios' Captain Marvel.
It's available for
digital download now.
So many visual effects.
The brains behind these
things are bigger than me.
It's mind-blowing.
It really is mind-blowing.
But you know what
else is mind-blowing?
I've got one bit of itty bitty
kitty trivia for you guys.
I was waiting for
the rest of that.
I think this is so cool.
You know, ginger cats,
IRL, In Real Life,
tend to be genetically male.
So our first hint that Goose
is a little bit different
is that she is female.
All the clues.
Yeah.
Isn't that good?
You fine out
all the knowledge.
I like that.
Yeah.
Listen, there are so
many more fun details
from the comic books
about flerkens.
- Sure.
- Let's talk about those, right?
Yeah.
Why don't we give
these guys four flerken
facts from the comic books.
OK.
Number one, how
the tentacles work.
So in the comics,
flerkens contain
these pocket dimensions
that don't just help
hold those pink tentacles, no.
They can also carry
anything up to the size
of a whole dang universe.
Simply put, flerkens are
bigger on the inside.
Well, you know, in the
comics, these pocket dimensions
are actually very handy for
teleportation and time travel
if you don't mind getting
covered in a bunch of pink goo.
It's damp.
It's a damp way to travel,
but it's convenient.
But also, that makes
sense of how a flerken
could just end up on Earth.
Yeah.
Also, hey, check this out.
Flerkens are oviparous.
It's a word for you, which
means like birds and reptiles,
they lay eggs,
like lots of eggs,
like a crazy amount of eggs.
LORRAINE CINK: Yeah,
it's a lot of eggs.
But don't say anything mean
about these cute little fluff
fluffs, because they actually
have human level intelligence.
So brains, and
beauty, and tentacles.
LANGSTON BELTON: And tentacles.
Watch out for the tentacles.
See, you learn
something new every day.
I love that.
Well, hey.
Let's keep the fun rolling with
more '90s goodness, because it
is Marvel's 80th anniversary.
And this month, we are
celebrating-- you guessed it--
the '90s as we take
a walk down memory
lane with our
friendly neighborhood
toy hunter Jordan Hembrough.
Oh, toy-riffic.
Let's check it out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Earth's Mightiest
Show fans, what is up?
I'm hanging out again
with my good buddy,
pop culture expert, Marvel
toy hunter extraordinaire
Jordan Hembrough.
Jordan, welcome back, my friend.
Thank you so much.
I am happy to be here.
I am happy that you are
here, because as you can see,
in front of you are some toys
from a wonderful decade that
we are celebrating here for
Marvel's 80th anniversary,
the '90s.
A decade that I grew up in.
I was born in 1985.
Oh, you're in for a treat.
Well, I cannot wait.
You're in for a treat.
These are Sneaker
Snappers from the 1990s.
This is what I love about these.
Let me-- no, no, hear me out.
They snapped on the
front of your sneakers.
And it was like really a
wearable kind of cool piece
of fashion that you would
wear to tell everyone,
I'm a Marvel fan.
I will tell you right now.
I owned these Sneaker Snappers.
Oh, there you go.
Really?
Because my shoes would
always come undone.
JORDAN HEMBROUGH:
In the industry,
what we essentially
call something
like this is it branches from
the toy category into something
we call lifestyle.
And that means that basically
you can use it every day.
I'm speechless
because I owned these.
These-- what?
These are yours.
What?
We talk about
the 1990s and toys.
You cannot not talk
about the X-Men.
Whoa!
What?
I definitely own this Wolverine.
Definitely had Wolverine.
Definitely had this one.
JORDAN HEMBROUGH: These are
classic X-Men from Toy Biz.
During the 1990s, these
toys ruled the toy stores.
I've got to take a second
and talk about Rogue.
LANGSTON BELTON: Yeah.
JORDAN HEMBROUGH:
And you know what?
They didn't realize
how many females were
actually playing with the toys.
So what happened was Rogue
and Storm were shortpacked.
And what that meant is there
was only one or two of them
in every case of 12.
Toy Biz started
realizing, look, we've
got to start making more Rogue.
We have to start
making more Storm.
We have to start bringing
these strong female superheroes
to life into the toy industry.
And they started making
more and more of them.
Jordan, I almost
don't want to move on.
Yeah.
This is my childhood
sitting right in front of me.
- I've got more.
- Yes, I know.
So let's do some more.
Yeah, I've got more.
All right.
LANGSTON BELTON: Get in.
JORDAN HEMBROUGH: Oh
Are you serious?
JORDAN HEMBROUGH: It's the
Spider-Man Animated Series
Daily Bugle Playset.
This was on a Christmas list.
Anyone who grew up
in the '90s loved
the Spider-Man Animated Series.
Animated Series.
It was a great piece.
It was expensive.
Yeah.
That's why I remember
the big thing.
My mom was like, no.
JORDAN HEMBROUGH: It was
packed full of as many factors
as they can get in one playset.
- Look at this.
If you look at all the
stuff that's on the back,
you see all the characters.
JORDAN HEMBROUGH: The
idea behind the playset
was to actually sell
more action figures,
because you created
a play environment,
and you created a
big play environment.
Well, guess what.
Now you've got to fill it.
- Yeah, right.
What are you going
to fill it with?
More toys.
Exactly.
I'd never, ever
thought I would ever
be this close to one of these.
My heart is always full
when you come back,
and I'm taken back
into my childhood.
This is so great.
All right.
LANGSTON BELTON: The Rage Cage.
JORDAN HEMBROUGH: This is
one of my favorite toys
from the 1990s.
And essentially
what it is, is you
put Hulk inside this giant cage.
And he rages out and
bursts through the cage.
And it's pandemonium,
and fun ensues.
I love when a toy says,
hey, we're going to give you
this cage with the Hulk in it.
Yeah.
I actually want to bring it out.
LANGSTON BELTON:
Try to rage him.
JORDAN HEMBROUGH: I want to
have you rage out with it.
LANGSTON BELTON: Let's try it.
JORDAN HEMBROUGH: OK.
So we're going to
rage out with it.
Rage!
[GROWLING]
It's amazing!
Hours of fun!
That is-- it's worth it.
It's so worth it.
Oh, the rage.
Jordan, thank you so, so much.
Ah, my pleasure.
If I'm-- if any of the
fans out there are like me,
they're going to
want to know more
about where to
find out more about
you and all these great toys.
Tell us more.
Absolutely.
OK.
Well, if you're
interested in toys,
you can find me on
Twitter, @JordanHembrough.
Instagram, @JordanHembrough.
Or if you feel so
inclined, check me
out at www.hollywoodheroes.com.
Check it out, because I'm
just going to stay in here
and stare at these,
and weep into my hands
for a couple of minutes,
because this is so great.
Oh, that was such a delight.
I feel like I was
transported to my childhood.
I was for sure.
And hey, shoutout to
Jordan Hembrough who let
me keep those Sneaker Stoppers.
Oh, really?
Does this mean
you're never going
to learn to tie your shoes?
Not for lack of trying, no.
Oh.
But hey, also, that
Spider-Man Daily Bugle Playset--
Also tried to steal it.
I-- it's too big.
It wouldn't fit anywhere.
I couldn't hide that.
You need a better coat.
I need a flerken.
Full circle.
You guys, you know what?
You tell us what
you would do if you
could spend a day with Goose
the Cat, a.k.a. a flerken.
And use the hashtag
#earthsmightiestshow.
We'll see you next time.
I'm Lorraine.
And I'm Langston.
And this is Marvel.
Your universe.
Meow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]